[Music]
let's go to taylor in knoxville what's
up taylor
hey how are you today i was good up
until that last transition there and i
blew it so we can get back on track here
what's up super great hey well
i wanted to get y'all's advice on
something
me and my husband have been going
through
um
and basically
my husband immigrated here to america
as as an adult he came here for school
we've been married for three years now
and
we are struggling and need advice on
facilitating
a conversation with his family that
still is living in south america his
home country
um
to really facilitate a conversation with
them so that we're not left
paying for them and their
living expenses which is what we're
doing we are supporting them okay
is uh
in a number of south american
cultures that's that's expected that's a
norm
um
is this something that your husband
feels like he's ready to part ways with
so
as a pac like when we were getting
married when we were preparing for
marriage we had the conversation and i
knew
that his mom would need to be supported
um
so that's totally
fine and that's something that we are
prepared to do
it has
gone to a place now where we're
supporting
more than just his mom
and i want to say that my husband is the
baby of all his siblings and he's
supporting
four siblings at this point
so let me let me ask my question in a
different way
you said we
are you done with this or is he done
with this too
he's done with it too um and it really
started at the first of the year we had
kind of a blowout with the family it
kind of spurred him realizing how done
with it he was
i've
i come from a different place i'm trying
to be
more patient i'm an only child okay
and the differences there are stark
i'm trying to be more giving but i'm
also trying to
get us in a place where they can be
self-sustaining so we can be
separate in our own way sure
um so you're dealing with some financial
realities and some
birth order realities and some just
cultural differences right which is
common and normal and can be confusing
and frustrating and super fun all that
all mixed into one
ultimately the question you're asking is
as simple as
here is what we as a
married couple
will agree to send away from our home
to care for your family
and we will send this much
and that's what we have to send the rest
of it we're gonna give every dollar a
name the rest of us gonna go to paying
our debts off to buying us a home to
providing some stability for our family
unit here in
the united states
and whatever number you agree on is
probably going to be way less than he
feels
comfortable and that doesn't mean that
he feels that it's wrong but he's gonna
wish he had more money to send home to
take care of everybody okay and it's
probably gonna be more than you would
like to because you'd like to keep all
the money you make right
and we're going to agree on a number and
then we're not going to fight about it
anymore
and then here's the deal
you cannot make his family
self-reliant that's a choice they have
to make
um you can't make him feel less guilty
he's gonna feel some guilt because his
life is gonna look different than his
brothers and his sisters and his family
okay what you can do is you all agree on
this thing together and you can support
each other as you experience these ups
and downs
does that sound fair
it's not fair um
there's not let me say this there's not
a conversation you're gonna have with
his family it's gonna go well
okay that doesn't that won't exist
there's not a magic line that he's going
to call him and be like i decided
they're going to go oh okay cool that's
not going to happen
right he's tried to have conversations
and tried to explain
with his
siblings like his siblings are just a
few years older than him but like i said
he's the baby
and
those conversations
as well intentioned as they are they end
with
him being
a villain
in their eyes and it's very emotional
and it's very
well what are we gonna do so at some
point you have to stop having a
conversation because it's not fruitful
yeah one of my core tenets is only speak
if you can be heard and right now
his family has proven to him he can't be
heard
they're going to keep beating him down
and beating him down until they get what
they want from him which is not his
relationship it's his money
if the relationship is hinging on a
paycheck then there was no relationship
so if this money stops and they decide
to disown him that's something you guys
have to own and move on as a boundary
and go alright that sucks that we can't
be family anymore but this can't
continue because they're taking
advantage of them at this point this is
not generosity right
it's all it's almost yeah
it's gotten to the point where well it's
been at this point for a long time
that we don't call to check in on them
because we're
just waiting for them to call
with whatever the new drama is
and
that's not a place that we want to be in
we
are trying to have family moments
together you don't get to choose those
moments
okay
there a plug like uh the end of an
outlet
like the end of an extension cord has to
have a plug that will receive it for the
electricity to channel through and you
could be the greatest end of an
extension cord but if you're just trying
to jam it into a wall it won't go in
there there's no plug that will receive
it
and if they want 2 500 of your money
every month and you've decided we can
afford 500 bucks just to send to support
grandma and a couple of other nicks and
necks or to support mom
that's what you can do and if they don't
want to be in a relationship to you then
that's their choice and that's for you
to grieve and be upset about but what
you're not owning is that you control
the other side of this thing
you at some point you have to accept and
make peace that somebody wants to be in
a relationship with you only as much as
you will give them cash
yeah and that's heartbreaking and it
stinks because that's not the way that
we want it to be in our hearts and minds
we want all of our families to get along
and have great memories and adventures
and we're going to go visit there and
they're going to come visit here
and the reality is it doesn't often work
like that in families
how much are you sending every month
taylor total
so right now um because mom and sister
live together we're sending
400
um that pays for their apartment and
their bills let's back i want to back up
real quick i want to back up on it back
up has nothing to do with mom or sister
it's not why you're sending money
you're sending money because y'all are
choosing to send 400
okay i think which i mean
i don't even know for choosing because
the sustainability of life there is is a
whole lot different than it is here
exactly that's something that i also
struggle to understand is
because i mean for our relationship to
continue like we have been having a
relationship with them as we pay for
their planes to come up here
and visit us they just stayed with us
for two months
through the holidays but if you're broke
and you can't eat and you can't pay your
rent
then that's going to get cut off
eventually anyway i'd much rather see
you guys build a sustainable financial
life for yourselves
so that you can give when you're able to
but right now you're not able to and
it's causing a lot of problems in your
home okay
decide what you're going to send and
send it and if they don't want to be a
part of your life it stinks i know but
you got to grieve it you got to be about
making something new